if I have to redesign the world I will
start with one simple issue and I think
it will lead to all solutions and that
is one there is no way we can solve any
issues whether it is economic growth and
stability GDPs growth health issues
environmental issue poverty and all
other prices if we do not get woman at
the center and core of the decision
making and I do not mean by microcredit
I actually mean women at the boardrooms
I mean women of farmers and mean woman
at workers war workers and in the
management table I mean women as half of
the decision-making authorities in how
to redesign of all that I also with mean
women in terms of getting half of the
resources failing for to fully include
women in the future design of the world
the group is a failing in creating a
sustainable solution for all of humanity
it is time to fully include women for I
cannot see us growing and live in this
table and in sustainable world without
the full inclusion of oil